salut à tous je ne sais pas vous mais
moi je fais partie d'une génération qui
a grandi avec l'union européenne à qui
il semble naturel et à qui on a appris
qu'elle était l'avenir indépassable de
la france du coup bien qu'ayant voté non
au traité constitutionnel européen en
2005 j'ai longtemps eu du mal à penser
la france hors de l'union européenne
et aujourd'hui encore peut-être à cause
de cette éducation et bien pour moi la
question de l'appartenance ou non à
l'union européenne n'est pas une
question centrale
la question étant plutôt de savoir ce
qu'on peut réellement faire à
l'intérieur de celle-ci mais récemment
avec la proche des élections européennes
je me suis posé une question qui n'avait
jamais effleuré avant est-ce que l'union
est une démocratie
est-ce que structurellement elle répond
aux critères des démocraties libérales à
savoir notamment la séparation des
pouvoirs et du coup je me suis penché
sur la question de la répartition des
pouvoirs au sein de l'union européenne
vous avez trois structures la commission
le parlement et le conseil de l'union
européenne
la commission est un organe exécutif
sorte de gouvernement de l'union
européenne
elle a aussi l'exclusivité de
l'initiative législative
elle propose des lois européennes et les
directives qui ne sont pas des lois mais
des feuilles de route conduisant à des
lois nationales et sans elle il n'y a
donc pas d'acte législatif le parlement
lui est élu par les citoyens par pays
ils votent les lois mais ne peut pas en
proposer et puis vous avez le conseil de
l'union européenne regroupant les
ministres des pays membres le conseil
permet de coordonner les politiques
étatiques et ils votent les lois en duo
avec le parlement ces deux structures
doivent accepter une loi pour qu'elle
soit validée avant on parlait de façon
très claire de système de co décision le
conseil valide aussi seuls les
directives émises par la commission
même s'il peut aussi demander l'avis du
parlement le système de directive permet
donc au conseil et à la commission de se
passer du parlement si on veut vraiment
se raccrocher à un fonctionnement
institutionnel qu'on connaît le
parlement et le conseil fonctionne un
peu comme un système bicaméral fédéral
de type suisse ou américains avec une
chambre haute
ici le conseil qui représente les
citoyens en tant que membre des états
fédérés et une chambre basse le
parlement représentant les citoyens en
tant que membre de l'union
sauf que vous vous en êtes certainement
aperçu la séparation des pouvoirs n'est
pas respectée deux des trois organes
le conseil et la commission cumul
pouvoirs exécutif et législatif
parce que oui si la commission ne vote
pas la loi être la seule instance à
pouvoir déclencher le pro
c'est sus législatif c'est déjà une
forme de pouvoir législatif énorme et le
conseil lui a des pouvoirs exécutif et
législatif au niveau européen et ses
membres ont un pouvoir exécutif au
niveau national et là ça pose de très
grosses questions
le conseil n'est pas un corps législatif
élu il est certes constitué des
gouvernements nationaux issus des urnes
mais ils n'ont pas les caractéristiques
d'un corps législatif ils ne sont pas
représentatifs de toute la diversité des
opinions de la population
même quand il s'agit de gouvernement de
coalition contrairement à un corps
directement élu par le peuple et ensuite
ces gouvernements sont par définition au
sein de leurs pays respectifs des
organes exécutifs qui par la magie
supranationale hérite au niveau européen
d'un pouvoir législatif
depuis quand dans une démocratie normale
bien portante un pouvoir exécutif à un
échelon devient législatif à l'échelon
supérieur
et la question que je me pose dans tout
ça c'est quel moment des démocraties ont
décidé qu'elle allait se fédérer créer
une structure commune qui ne
respecteraient aucun de leurs standards
et leurs principes de bases
démocratiques et il réduira leurs
citoyens que c'est leur avenir
à quel moment ça leur a semblé cohérent
bien sûr c'est à comprendre à travers
l'histoire de l'union européenne depuis
le début ce qu'on cherche avant tout à
construire c'est une puissance
économique continentale
les pères fondateurs qui personne
d'ailleurs n'a demandé de fonder quoi
que ce soit vous voyez avant tout la
construction de l'europe comme la
construction d'un marché permettant de
lier les états entre eux et donc
d'empêcher structurellement la guerre
bilan la plupart des traités des étapes
d'intégration européenne sont avisés
économique et on ne nous a vendu
réellement l'europe démocratique qu'à
partir des années 90 comme un petit plus
on est passé progressivement d'organes
internationaux de coopération sur des
sujets économiques circonscrit qui n'ont
pas besoin de démocratie à des organes
d'une proto démocratie fédérale
une fois le marché européen construit
comme si une démocratie pouvait naître
d'un marché on n'a jamais vu ça dans
l'histoire les peuples quand ils veulent
la démocratie là veulent pour elle même
pour pouvoir gérer leurs affaires pas
comme un décorum pour un projet de
marché mais cette évidence pour vous et
moi ne semble pas en être une pour les
technocrates de bruxelles avec autant
d'entorses aux principes démocratiques
peut-on considérer l'union européenne
comme un projet réellement démocratiques
si un gouvernement du tiers-monde e
fonctionnel
cette façon avec autant de confusion
entre les pouvoirs il serait vite accusé
d'être une république bananière et
personnellement après cette petite
réflexion je ne suis pas loin de penser
que l'union européenne en est bien une
pourtant il était simple de faire de
vieux os une démocratie et pour cela il
fallait quelqu'un son fonctionnement sur
celui de la suisse ou des états unis ont
fait une chambre haute qui représente
les citoyens par état et dans ce cas là
chaque état a le même nombre d'élus
n'ont fait une chambre basse qui
représente les citoyens en tant que
membre de l'union ce qui dans ce cas
implique de faire des listes
transnationales entre partis frères mais
bon tout ça c'est de la vie et de
l'analyse personnel et du coup pour la
petite anecdote je me suis aussi demandé
si on ne pourrait pas analysé la
démocratie européenne de façon un petit
peu plus neutre
il existe des indices sur la corruption
internationale ou sur la liberté de la
presse et du coup je me suis demandé si
riposté lundi ce qui pouvait mesurer la
démocratie et j'en ai trouvé un réalisé
par le journal the economist
c'est un indice assez simple à réaliser
constitué d'une soixantaine de questions
à points répartis en 5 sous catégories
ce qui donne 5 note sectorielle sur 10
et une moyenne globale qui permet
ensuite d'effectuer un classement
international
bien sûr ce questionnaire est destiné à
des pays et pas des unions
supranationale et il faut adapter un peu
pour certaines parties mais bon c'est
mieux que rien vous même vous trouverez
certainement des chiffres légèrement
différent si vous faites ce
questionnaire mais je pense que le
pattern sera le même maintenant venons
en résultats l'union européenne a une
note moyenne globale de 6 98 ce qui la
place selon le barème deux économistes
parmi les démocraties imparfaites mais
ce chiffre est un peu trompeur car il ya
de fortes disparités entre les scores
des différentes sous parties en détail
pour ce qui est des domaines des
élections et des libertés individuelles
on est dans un standards très élevés
l'union européenne est bien l'enfant de
démocratie libérale
mais quand on regarde les trois autres
indicateurs c'est moins joyeux on est à
6 4 sur 10 pour ce qui est du
fonctionnement démocratique du
gouvernement à 5,5 sur 10 pour ce qui
est de la participation politique des
citoyens et pire que tout à 4 3 sur 10
pour ce qui est de la culture
démocratique européenne ce qui est au
niveau d'un pays autoritaires en fait là
où l'on mesure l'efficience des
procédures électorales et les libertés
on a de très haut niveau
mais là où l'on mesure l'engagement et
le contrôle citoyen où on mesure la
vigueur de la démocratie
on est à
niveau lamentable signe qu'il n'y a pas
de démocraties européennes de un parce
que les structures ne sont pas
réellement démocratique et de deux parce
que les peuples ne se vivent pas comme
un corps civique transnationales or la
démocratie implique de se sentir
appartenir un même corps civique
on le voit bien avec ce barème pour
construire l'union européenne même par
en haut il aurait fallu mener une
politique de civilisation plutôt qu'une
politique économique comme préambule à
la démocratie mais de fait on ne peut
pas rester avec cette république
bananière supranationale ce n'est pas
cohérent avec nos démocraties libérales
et de fait on n'a que deux solutions
soit on transforme lieux en état fédéral
soit on en revient à ce qu'elle était à
l'origine à savoir des organismes de
coopération sur des sujets ponctuels et
dans ce cas là on n'a pas besoin de
démocratie et c'est sur cet avis qui
vaut bien celui d'un technocrate
européen que cette vidéo se termine
s'il vous a intéressé n'hésitez pas à la
partager et à vous abonner à la chaîne
si c'est pas déjà fait et sur ce je vous
dis à la prochaine
[Musique]